auch am sonntag wird im salzburger
russbach an der ersatzbrücke für die bei
unwetter zerstörte neuhaus brücke mit
hochdruck gearbeitet
62 pioniere und zu pionieren
ausgebildete rekruten des
österreichischen bundesheeres sind mit
allem was notwendig ist ausgerückt um
die straßenverbindung wiederherzustellen
sie freuen sich dass wir können wir
sagen dass wir die verkehrsverbindung
wieder herstellen und eine hochreine
draufgeht für so was ja für uns ist das
große problem wir wohnen nicht nur ums
boxen und arbeit nur in ruse burg vor
dem verfahren wir normalerweise 30
minuten und jetzt wasser zwei stunden
umweg beziehungsweise müssen wir immer
auto zu fuß auto so warum tun und was
den ruß burg arbeiten zudem erst richtig
dass die bürger so schnell wie möglich
wieder aufgebaut wird das sehr gut
doch in der kaserne die brücke oft
aufbaut haben schritt für schritt dass
man uns hört dann leichter dann hier im
echten einsatz die brücke aufzubauen
grundausbildung war es nur der dessen
was einmal in der praxis umsetzen
die instandsetzung der behelfsbrücke
läuft ohne verzögerung ganz nach dem
leitspruch der österreichischen pionier
soldatinnen und soldaten pioniere wie
immer